ccsd will be meeting this thursday to go
over its plan for the upcoming school
year take a closer look at what the
district is calling the
path forward plan now the district is
offering three separate learning models
full-time face-to-face instruction which
currently 95 percent
of the district's 230 000 students are
registered for
the district serves more than 320 000
students but not everyone is registered
at this point
another option is of course the
full-time distance education
and hybrid instruction on a limited
basis
as for the path forward plan for
distance education
all students will be issued a
district-owned device the district will
subsidize
internet connections for families
without in-home internet connectivity
who
meet those certain eligibility
requirements and all students may
participate in full-time distance
education either at their assigned zone
school
or at the nevada learning academy at
ccsd
the plan for the safe return to school
for in-person instruction
calls for the following mass wearing
policies that were newly updated
as of june all staff are required to
wear a mask indoors if they are not
fully vaccinated and regardless of
vaccination status they are required on
school buses
as for students it's optional for
students in pre-k through grades three
it is required for students in grades
four and five
optional for students in grades 6
through 12 who have been fully
vaccinated
and regardless of vaccination status
required on all school buses
but no one is required to wear a mask
outdoors